and so I got invited to Birmingham to go
to this convention called star Fury and
I had a lovely time and met not just
wonderful fans but also friends I mean
Felicia Day and I became friends there
Miracle Laurie and I became friends
there
um but uh but I I realized oh and also
we got to this it was really funny
because there was a campaign going on
for Chuck at the time I think because I
think it was like the end of the second
season or something and there was a big
fan campaign to like save the show
Subway was one of our main sponsors and
even like product placement tie-ins we
had it on the show all the time it I
liked it was a really good product
placement in that we just leaned into it
it was so like winking to the audience
how about that foot long you know as
opposed to like trying to make it subtle
and like as if it's a part of natural
dialogue in a show to talk about any
product for that matter right and we
don't get paid for the commercial anyway
um but but it was really fun because
there was a Subway literally around the
corner the the the the campaign was
happening like right then that weekend
because the finale was was airing
and somebody told me there was a Subway
around the corner and I was like and and
Adam and I we had already done one panel
Adam Baldwin thank you very good uh who
was the illustrious Casey on Chuck
um we had already done one panel and and
it wasn't as small uh that big of a
convention so like everybody who was at
the convention who wanted to go to the
panel basically already saw the panel
and we had one other panel and I said I
said well what if we just like what if
we just like instead of doing the panel
what if we just invited everybody to go
to Starbucks or to uh Subway and I did I
just said hey uh so the foot long finale
is going on right now we've already
talked about all the things we can talk
about who wants to go get a sandwich and
we and I marched everyone how many
people marched with you to Subway a
hundred maybe about that
marching one by one hurray all the way
from the convention center all the way
and it was close I mean it wasn't like
you know far far away but we had to like
walk across this like you know I don't
know Business Center kind of area you
were Rocky essentially bro way Rocky be
rocking all the way up those steps and
then and then we had a mat by the way
the poor people at Subway had we gave
tried to give them a heads up but they
were still not prepared for the amount
of people that were they were about to
get hit with and so because it was
moving as slowly as it was I was like yo
let me let me get back there so I
started making sandwiches with the
Sandwich Artist by the way I became a
sandwich artist for today wow I know I
know
um but anyway so I say all that to say
it was a really memorable and lovely
time I I I'm so glad that I did it but
one of the things that dawned on me in
that in that weekend was I don't really
have a lot to talk about I don't have a
resume I don't have a I don't have a
career in this particular World sci-fi
genre fantasy nerd culture whatever
um to sit at a table not that I wasn't
worthy anybody's worthy of going and
sitting at that table if you've been
invited or whatever and you want to go
sit there but to me I felt like I want
to go build a bit more of this stuff
they'll come back so when people come to
the table they have multiple things that
they might have enjoyed of of mine and